This Saturday, October 9, at
the East Las Vegas Community Center
located in the Eastern In Store, we are
celebrating Binational Health Week.
This is an event that we bring to the
community in coordination and cooperation
with the
Mexican Consulate Health Desk.  and also to rich the
binational health week is basically
a space that we offer to our
community so that they can find out how
we can have optimal health health
we see many migrants who
sometimes have scarce resources
in this area and this this is a
opportunity to come in for a
shock a glucose check a
blood pressure
check a general medical consultation and where
you can connect with other
medical resources in the community apart from
immunizations there will also be
eye exams exams that  determine how
your blood pressure is doing and also if
you need resources for your
mental health there we will have all this at your
provision